cosa vuol dire andare oltre e forse
un'esperienza esclusiva riservata
qualche raro intrepido avventuriero del
limite dotato di straordinario talento
io non credo io penso che l'andare oltre
sia la chiave di lettura della vita
il codice unico originale per realizzare
interpretare se stessi e talenti con cui
si nasce con cui ognuno di noi nasce e
che rischiano di restare soffocati tra i
molti condizionamenti che si subiscono
talenti che invece se sviluppati
andrebbero a sostenerci nel percorso di
crescita personale e portandoci verso
benessere salute e felicità felicità lo
so che è una parola grande che spesso
scatena scetticismo però le neuroscienze
ci danno una buona notizia e ci dicono
che la felicità è una competenza e
quindi proprio come una competizione
necessita di preparazione educazione
allenamento motivazione e io aggiungo
anche consapevolezza del limite
ecco quando penso alla complessità del
concetto di limite e alla sua enorme
importanza per la nostra crescita
personale
l'unica analogia che trovo pertinente è
quella con il fenomeno della
supercompensazione la metodologia
dell'allenamento è quella disciplina che
studia i mezzi e metodi atti a
sviluppare il talento sportivo e
portarlo alle sue massime potenzialità
prestati ve il principio cardine della
metodologia dell'allenamento è la super
compensazione che si basa sulle evidenza
fisiologica che il nostro organismo vive
in omeostasi se noi siamo in grado di
somministrare un allenamento che va da
stimolare il limite che segna il confine
tra l'equilibrio e il disequilibrio
inneschiamo un meccanismo di
compensazione che poi si trasforma in
supercompensazione andando andando a
ripristinare sileno stasi ma un livello
significativamente superiore
questo è il meccanismo che ci ha
permesso di evolverci di adattarci di
migliorarci la cosa interessante è che
però il miglioramento avviene solo se
noi somministriamo lo stimolo allenante
nella fase acuta della super
compensazione che quella che si verifica
solo dopo che sono stati elaborati e
assorbiti tutti gli effetti dello
stimolo precedente se noi non
rispettiamo questo tempo dando stimoli
troppo ravvicinati
andiamo in sindrome da hoover training
al contrario se osserviamo pause troppo
lunghe
l'organismo resta in uno stato di
sostanziale immobilità
ecco quando mi chiedono se il limite sia
un confine da osservare o una soglia da
varcare non posso che rispondere
tutte e due e probabilmente questo
dualismo è insito nella natura stessa
del concetto visto che anche
etimologicamente limite ha una doppia
radice limes limitis l'email i minis che
significano proprio confine e soglia
quindi il limite è un confine che
definisce un ambito l'adattamento e la
familiarità a quell'ambito mi consente
di trovare gli stimoli per andare un po
oltre
un po come succede con un orizzonte che
man mano che mi avvicino si sposta un po
quella è evidente che talento e limite
sono due concetti imprescindibili l'uno
dall'altro e che lo sviluppo del talento
ha bisogno dello sforzo dell'impegno
della fatica di muoversi in quella terra
di confine che il limite rappresenta ma
non è un movimento che devo fare solo
quello
una dimensione fisica ma anche con
quella psichica
infatti le analogie tra fisico e
psichico sono più che evidenti
l'omeostasi e la zona comfort il
disequilibrio è la crisi la
compensazione è l'adattamento e questo
limite che diventa soglia questo
disequilibrio che torna 1 stasi ma un
livello superiore in una famiglia tanto
al concetto di resilienza del negativo
che diventa positivo del problema che si
trasforma in opportunità ecco la
sensazione che il limite sia un confine
che definisce un ambito verso il quale
io sviluppo sia un adattamento fisico
che psichico non mi consente quindi di
parlare di ecologia del limite e di uso
lo sviluppo sostenibile del talento
attraverso la mia storia
vorrei dirgli di sì che si può
i due ori olimpici nel ciclismo su pista
sono senza dubbio il fiore all'occhiello
della mia carriera ma non è questa la
ragione se talvolta ancora il mondo
dello sport si ricorda di me la cosa
rilevante è che io ho iniziato con
l'atletica leggera e ha terminato con il
bob a 2
sono stata un'atleta molto precoce a 16
anni faceva già parte di quella
meravigliosa squadra nazionale assoluta
anni 80 tra cui sara simeoni gabriella
dorio io facevo letto sono l'equivalente
femminile del decathlon
ma la mia disciplina forte erano i 100
metri ad ostacoli record su record
vittoria su vittoria il mio destino
sembrava scolpito nella pietra invece
accade l'imprevisto un infortunio al
ginocchio mi bloccò iniziai un
lunghissimo pellegrinaggio di medico e
medico ma inutilmente non vi arrivò anzi
le terapie spesso peggioravano la
situazione
e così dopo più di due anni di
resistenza ostinata
esausta dovetti rassegnarmi accettare la
situazione e lasciarne ispirare da
quello che questa nuova esperienza aveva
in serbo per me un gruppo di amici
triatleti mi convinsero per riabilitarli
ad andare in bicicletta e così ne
comprai una di seconda mano e iniziai a
pedalare verso il mio incontro con la
serendipità non volevo dire serenità ma
proprio serendipità sapete no questo
bellissimo termine che indica il trovare
qualcosa di inaspettato mentre si sta
cercando qualcos'altro
il misto tra il vizio dell'ingegno e la
coincidenza fortuita che spesso alla
base di rivelazioni positive per la
quotidianità così come anche di scoperte
ed invenzioni
ecco io che volevo solo riabilitarmi nel
corpo e nell'anima
mi ritrovo di nuovo in pista questa
volta un velodromo all'inseguimento del
mio sogno olimpico
non fu facile non fu per niente facile
non lo fu emotivamente perché mi
chiamavano la marziana o quella uscita
da blade runner e già questo spiega
tutto ma sapete come avviene la
accettazione del nuovo meglio del
diverso deve passare attraverso le tra
forche caudine della resistenza della
derisione e solo alla fine se vinci e
talvolta nemmeno in quel caso arriva
l'accettazione non fu facile
psicologicamente perché realizzare un
progetto completamente nuovo è anche una
questione di fiducia e non esistono
riferimenti se non quelli che tu stessa
sta tracciando e non fu facile nemmeno
all'interno del mio stesso staff che era
diviso tra detrattori e sostenitori
ricordo come fosse ieri il giorno in cui
mi visitò per la prima volta il medico
della squadra nazionale e mi disse
guarda prima che tu investa troppo in
questa parte nuova disciplina
vorrei dirti senza offesa ma tu non ha
il fisico adatto per correre in
bicicletta le cicliste hanno un'altra
morfologia
e aveva ragione fino a quel momento era
veramente così non fu più così però dopo
i giochi olimpici di atlanta 1996 a meno
di due anni da quella frase quando vinsi
la medaglia d'oro nella gara dei 3 km
con record del mondo e record olimpico
fece scalpore tutto la mia storia
tra tema
sapete che non ve lo dico per questo ma
è solo perché sappiate che se una cosa
non è mai successa non è detto che non
debba succedere mai bene quindi fece
scalpore tutto ovviamente i risultati la
mia storia la posizione con cui corsi
definita la miglior posizione ore
dinamica mai vista il rapporto più sai
proibitivo anche per un uomo in una gara
con partenza da fermo e il modello di
prestazione venne completamente
stravolto da gara di mezzofondo veloce
divenne una gara di resistenza alla
velocità quattro anni dopo ai giochi
olimpici di sydney e per confermare la
mia carriera all'insegna dell'eclettismo
rivinco la medaglia d'oro ma in un'altra
disciplina la corsa a punti specialità
sulla quale investa dopo che la
federazione ciclistica internazionale e
decide di porre un limite alla lunghezza
massima della bicicletta che mi
impedisce di fatto di correre nella
stessa posizione con quei corsi ad
atlanta diventò così per diritto
conquistato sul campo un importante
testimone del trasferimento del talento
che a me piace chiamare riciclo per via
del mio animo ambientalista e anche un
po provocatoriamente perché so che
questo termine evoca spesso sentimenti
negativi è invece presente per la
spontanea spontanea associazione al
concetto di rifiuto e invece ora che
emergesse in tutta la sua bellezza
perché riciclare vuol dire rimettere in
circolo rinnovare ridare vita a ciò che
non ne ha più
bene dopo la mia esperienza il concetto
del trasferimento del talento viene
accettato un studiato e portato come
risorsa per rivalorizzare i talenti
persi bruciati per studiare i transfer
positivi tra le diverse discipline tra
l'apprendimento motorio e cognitivo per
ridurre i danni da iperspecializzazione
e anche per dare uno scossone ai
compartimenti stagni e io direi anche ai
comportamenti stagni che
l'iperspecializzazione crea nello sport
così come in tanti altri ambiti della
società isolando e impedendo sinergie
se devo riconoscere un denominatore
comune dei risultati diversamente
importanti della mia storia sportiva e
non sportiva senza ombra di dubbio ci
terrei la formazione perché io sono nata
e cresciuta con un allenatore che
credeva tantissimo in polivalenza
multilateralità e multidisciplinarietà
forte del nella convinzione che e piu
ricco è il vocabolario motorio più ampia
e solida può essere la base e di
conseguenza più alto il vertice della
mia piramide prestativa certo è che
parlare di multidisciplinarietà con
l'iperspecializzazione che sta vivendo
la società moderna può sembrare un
paradosso ma io la trovo
l'unica risposta alla necessità di
vedere le cose nel loro insieme perché
più sofisticato più complicato è un
sistema e maggiore è l'esigenza di
saperlo vedere nella sua totalità credo
che il concetto di multidisciplinarietà
abbia inoltre un'importante funzione
anche per la crescita personale
perché è proprio dalle nostre esperienze
diverse dai nostri tanti talenti che il
pensiero divergente attinge per dare
vita alla creatività e darci la
possibilità di rinnovarci che non è un
esigenza solo per gli atleti zoppi
ostinati come lo ero io lo è sicuramente
per tutti gli atleti visto che la
carriera seppur di successo e
fisiologicamente breve è una necessità
per tutti perché chiunque può capitare
di accorgersi di aver imboccato la
strada sbagliata oppure di subire un
intoppo o ancora a chiunque può capitare
di aver bisogno di stimoli nuovi per
continuare a fare bene quello che già
sta facendo e infine credo che la
multidisciplinarietà
abbiamo un importante funzione anche dal
punto di vista pedagogico perché vuol
dire elasticità vuol dire tolleranza
capacità di vedere nella diversità un
valore e anche non restare ancorati alle
etichette
non aver paura di dimostrarsi
vulnerabili di mettersi in gioco in
ambiti diversi
una volta durante un'intervista un
giornalista mi chiese ma perché quando
sei guarita non è ricominciato a fare
atletica e la mia risposta fu la stessa
per la quale non continuare a correre in
bicicletta quando con due ori olimpici
al collo forse finalmente avrei anche
potuto capitalizzare qualcosa per
lanciarne invece con il bob verso le
olimpiadi invernali di salt lake city
la mia risposta fu la quotidianità
perché perché ha in sé due grandi rischi
che allenarsi diventi sinonimo di
alienarsi è che il desiderio ripieghi su
se stesso diventando un'ossessione è
l'unico rimedio che conosco
a questi pericoli è quello di porsi un
obiettivo che sia sentito col cuore
prima che pensato con la mente capace di
riempire di entusiasmo il duro lavoro
quotidiano il qui e ora
perché ricordiamoci che il talento senza
applicazione è nullo e ce lo ricorda
bene la teoria dei dieci anni di bloom
ecco se io riesco a fare questo la
centralità dell'attenzione si sposta non
è più sull'obiettivo
ma sul percorso che intraprendo per
raggiungerlo
quindi non vivo in attesa del futuro e
nell'ansia del risultato che potrei
anche non ottenere ma vivo e mi
arricchisco delle esperienze che il
percorso intrapreso mi offre così
facendo trasformo il presente che è
l'unico tempo che abbiamo in un dono
continuo
ecco mi piacerebbe che anche del limite
se ne parlasse come di una competenza
che ha bisogno di educazione
preparazione motivazione per portarci
tutti un po oltre
talvolta per diventare grandi campioni
grande artisti grandi scienziati
ma sempre per portarci un po oltre
quello che noi sappiamo di noi stessi
dove ciò che ci unisce ci completa e ci
dà felicità è molto più di ciò che ci
divide simbolicamente ho voluto
intitolare a questi pensieri il limite
ignoto perché vorrei rappresentassero il
mio piccolissimo e personalissimo
monumento in memoria dei tanti talenti
che si perdono e si spengono prima
ancora di essere stati riconosciuti
grazie